lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
hablar sobre los experimentos en ciencia
los experimentos son el corazón de todo
progreso científico si imaginamos esta
línea como el conocimiento básico habrá
personas que tienen alguna corazonada de
que esto o aquello es bueno para la
salud pero si no tienen una forma de
comprobar estas corazonadas o de medir
qué tan confiables son pues éstas no
pueden formar parte del conocimiento y
tampoco pueden usarse para generar más
conocimiento pero con los experimentos y
con el método científico podemos
establecer hipótesis y diseñar buenos
experimentos para probarlas de manera
que el resultado de dichos experimentos
nos ayuda a confirmar o descartar estas
hipótesis y generar nueva información y
más adelante otras personas pueden usar
esta nueva información para generar
otras hipótesis que a su vez puedan
comprobarse
o descartarse con otros experimentos y
así generar más conocimiento esto ocurre
una y otra vez de manera que al final
tenemos un gran progreso científico
acumulado durante cientos de años es
importante que los experimentos estén
bien diseñados para que no nos lleven a
conclusiones equivocadas y no se tenga
que descartar
aquello que se hizo con base en estas
conclusiones equivocadas aquí la
pregunta clave es cómo diseñar bien los
experimentos este es un campo de estudio
muy amplio pero en este vídeo veremos
sólo una introducción a este tema
comenzamos con una hipótesis vamos a
suponer que tenemos la hipótesis de que
una cápsula hecha con los pétalos de
cierta flor mejora la rapidez al correr
lo importante de cualquier hipótesis es
que tiene que ser comprobable así que
tenemos que pensar en cómo podemos
comprobar esta hipótesis para probar la
hipótesis digamos que vamos a dar la
cápsula a algunos corredores y comparar
el tiempo que tardan en correr 100
metros antes de tomar la cápsula y
después de tomar la cápsula y si mejora
el tiempo después de tomar la cápsula
entonces podemos pensar que la hipótesis
es correcta pausa en el vídeo y piensen
en si les convence este experimento para
probar la hipótesis la realidad es que
este experimento tiene varios problemas
uno de ellos es que no especifica cómo
vamos a seleccionar a los corredores y
si al darles la cápsula mejora su
velocidad como sabe
y esto se debió realmente a que tomarán
la cápsula y no se debe a otra cosa
quizá a la dieta que tienen es lo que
causa la mejora o quizá la mejora se
debió a que tienen zapatos nuevos o
podría ser algo psicológico llamado
efecto placebo que ocurre cuando las
personas toman algo que piensan que les
va a ayudar y que resulta que les ayuda
aunque lo que estén tomando sea una
cápsula que no contenga nada adentro o
sea una pastilla de azúcar cómo podemos
evitar este tipo de errores pues podemos
tener dos grupos de corredores estos
grupos van a tener corredores que hayan
sido elegidos aleatoriamente de la
población de corredores porque la
elección es aleatoria porque si no lo
hacemos así podemos tener un sesgo
implícito al elegir a los corredores
quizá elegimos a corredores cuyo tiempo
de carrera está mejorando y los
colocamos en el grupo que tomará la
cápsula así que la asignación de los
corredores a los grupos debe ser
aleatoria la razón para tener dos grupos
es que un grupo va a tomar la cápsula
con la sustancia que nos interesa probar
y quizás se vean tentados a no dar
cápsula alguna a este grupo y dejar
pasar algunos meses y analizar si hay
alguna diferencia
en el tiempo que tardan los corredores
en recorrer 100 metros en comparación
con el tiempo del grupo que no tomo la
cápsula pero hay que ser cuidadosos
porque si este grupo no toma la cápsula
y este grupo sí entonces es posible que
este grupo tenga efecto placebo y su
tiempo mejore por esa razón como una
profecía autocumplida aquí tenemos que
dar una cápsula a este grupo también
pero la cápsula de este grupo estará
vacía aunque por fuera se vea igual que
la cápsula del otro grupo otra idea que
hay que tomar en cuenta al diseñar estos
experimentos es que deben ser doble
ciego lo que significa que debemos ser
ciegos entre comillas ante dos cosas la
primera es que ninguna de estas personas
debe saber a qué grupo pertenece o qué
tipo de cápsula toma ya que si las
personas de este grupo saben que están
tomando una cápsula vacía entonces es
posible que no funciona el efecto
placebo y la otra cosa a la que se debe
estar ciego es que los investigadores a
cargo de observar a estos corredores y
de darles las cápsulas no deben de saber
con qué grupo están trabajando ya que si
lo hicieran es posible que se comportan
de forma diferente
pistas inconscientes que hagan saber a
los corredores a qué grupo pertenecen
imaginemos que tomamos en cuenta todas
estas cosas por lo que parece que
diseñamos un buen experimento y
encontramos que al comparar a las diez
personas de este grupo contra las diez
personas de este otro grupo al cabo de
tres meses los corredores de este grupo
tienen una mejora del 5% en su velocidad
de carrera mientras que los corredores
de este otro grupo tienen una mejora del
10% esto es suficiente para concluir que
nuestra hipótesis es correcta quizá nos
veríamos tentados a decir que sí pero es
en este momento cuando entra en juego la
estadística ya que hay cierta
probabilidad de obtener estos resultados
al azar que por casualidad hayamos
elegido a las personas que van a mejorar
por sí solas su rendimiento y que la
cápsula no hace nada hay todo un campo
de estudio de estadística inferencial
que se aprende en los cursos de
estadística y se encarga de estudiar
este aspecto en resumen lo que hacemos
es que suponemos que la cápsula no hace
nada y nos preguntamos cuál es la
probabilidad de tener este tipo de
resultados para 10 personas o cual
es la probabilidad de tener esta
diferencia en este intervalo si esa
probabilidad resulta ser muy pequeña
entonces podría sugerir que la cápsula
si tiene algún efecto otro aspecto
importante de este tipo de experimentos
es que tienen que ser replicables porque
aunque pensemos que hicimos un buen
trabajo al diseñar y realizar el
experimento es posible que las personas
no nos crean y a la ciencia es
importante que las personas sean
escépticas ya que cuando las personas
hacen un experimento tienen el deseo de
obtener algún resultado por lo que ese
sesgo puede afectar el resultado si
alguien más quiere replicar nuestro
experimento entonces debemos indicarles
exactamente como lo hicimos para que
ellos puedan replicarlo y ver si
obtienen los mismos resultados quizá no
tengan los mismos resultados porque
aunque nosotros hayamos seleccionado a
las personas aleatoriamente quizá
elegimos a personas de un solo país o
bajo ciertas condiciones climáticas o
suponiendo ciertas restricciones así que
otras personas pueden realizar el
experimento ligeramente diferente o con
otras restricciones y se den cuenta de
que esta mejora tiene otra
diferente a la de nuestra hipótesis una
cosa más a tener en cuenta es que
mientras más grande sea el tamaño de los
grupos con los que realizamos el
experimento más robustas serán las
estadísticas que encontremos estas
muestras no sólo deben ser más grandes
sino también más variadas y diversas en
cuanto a edad género ubicación
geográfica y etnicidad en resumen todo
el progreso científico se da cuando se
diseñan buenos experimentos y se es muy
riguroso en cuanto a la realización de
dichos experimentos esto que comentamos
en el vídeo es apenas una introducción
sobre que debemos considerar al diseñar
estos experimentos y conforme ustedes
avancen en sus carreras científicas los
invito a que observen los experimentos
de otras personas y vean cómo han sido
diseñados quizá muchas veces se den
cuenta de que los experimentos no fueron
tan rigurosamente diseñados como
deberían ser nos vemos en el siguiente
vídeo